bei uns mit im studio ist bild meinungs-
chef philipp ii hat philipp wenn wir das
hören peter sagt jetzt gerade na gut der
inzidenz wert bzw die inzidenz grenze 50
dies herausgestrichen worden das ist
erst mal eine ganz gute idee das hat
bild seit monaten gefordert aber warum
verlängert man dann überhaupt noch die
lage hätte man sich das nicht sparen
können ja das könnte man sich sparen
also so wie jens spahn gerade der
inzidenz einen abschied winken
zugewunken hat könnte man das eigentlich
auch mit der epidemischen lager machen
denn die frage ist doch haben wir eine
notlage droht das system irgendwie zu
kollabieren irgendwann in den nächsten
monaten ich würde sagen die antwort ist
nein das heißt dieses präventive
verhängen der epidemischen lage das muss
eigentlich nicht sein man kann sie ja
immer noch beschließen wenn man meint
dass die lage auch nur ansatzweise außer
kontrolle gerät aber das tut sie nicht
und ehrlich gesagt wenn sich die korona
lage zuspitzt dann helfen meistens auch
keine maßnahmen die regierung hat die
wirkung ihrer maßnahmen bislang komplett
überschätzt zb mit den ausgangssperren
mit diesem bundes lockdown mit der
bundes notbremse wie die kanzlerin sehr
getauft hat man tut jetzt so als wäre es
dieses maßnahmenpaket das die dritte
welle im frühjahr gebrochen habe das
stimmt nicht das war vor allem die
saisonalität und natürlich auch die
impfung sprechen saisonalität ganz kurz
das wetter das ist wärmer wurde das halt
das frühjahr kam bzw der sommer verebbt
ist völlig richtig dass haben einzelne
virologen auch genauso vorhergesagt sie
wurden lächerlich gemacht sie wurden
diffamiert das ihs nein nein es braucht
jetzt harte regierungsmaßnahmen aber es
lässt sich nun mal nicht nachweisen dass
viele dieser maßnahmen irgendeine
wirkung haben deswegen braucht es auch
keine epidemische notlage die jetzt
sparen wir uns gerade so charmant
zugewunken hat zu allem möglichen
ermächtigt hinter erklärt einmal genauer
die epidemische lage verlängern wen geht
das denn überhaupt mehr
handlungsspielraum und was zu tun
ja das ist eigentlich die grundlage
dafür dass der staat überhaupt in unsere
grundrechte eingreifen darf das darf er
nicht ohne not tun also muss er die note
stellen in form einer notlage in diesem
fall einer pandemie oder epidemie dann
halt die epidemische oder pandemischen
notlage von nationaler tragweite
nationaler tragweite ist ganz wichtig
weil sonst wäre der bund ja nicht
zuständig dann wäre es ja nun länder
ebene so hat man also mit dem ausrufen
dieser pandemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite hat man also dafür gesorgt
dass der bund tätig werden kann und alle
bundesländer so und david philipp hat ja
gerade beschrieben eigentlich ist sie ja
gerade gar nicht da also wir haben ja
keine notlage so und eigentlich könnte
man die auslaufen lassen und wenn es
dann wieder ganz schlimm kommen könnte
man sie eigentlich wieder einberufen
aber dann argumentieren jetzt zumindest
die befürworter dieser verlängerung dass
die bundesländer sonst keine handhabe
hätten für bestimmte maßnahmen
da kann man allerdings dann auch sagen
da müssen sich die länder hat und wie
selber kümmern also die möglichkeit wäre
da aber kurze erklärung ohne die
erklärung der pandemischen oder
epidemischen notlage von nationaler
tragweite hätten weder der bund noch
alle länder gleichzeitig handeln können
und ohne not kein eingriff in die
grundrechte die not ist aber momentan
nicht meter infiziert hat bei uns im
studio philipp du hast gerade auch in
unserem gespräch hat dagegen
argumentiert hat gesagt das ist
überhaupt gar nicht notwendig wie wäre
deine
meinung nach jetzt die richtige
vorgehensweise was wir die richtige
strategie damit man sie sind auch alle
so pandemie müde und blicken mit so
einer angst furcht und langsam schon
panik in den herbst was müsste die
politik jetzt tun um dort die richtige
strategie zu fahren also ich bin kein
politiker ich will nicht den
regierungskurs bestimmen aber ich frage
mich welche grundlage hat denn überhaupt
dieses staatliche handeln mit dem in
grundrechte eingeschritten wird die
frage ist doch ganz einfach steht eine
gefahr für das gesundheitswesen oder tut
sie es nicht derzeit tut sie es nicht
und viele experten sagen wenn sie auch
schon bislang nicht bestanden hat also
unser gesundheitssystem stand nie vor
dem kollaps dann wird es erst recht
jetzt nicht mehr passieren weil die
risikogruppen fast komplett durch
geimpft sind und dann fällt das argument
weg und wenn man in andere länder blickt
die fast komplett ohne massnahmen
durchgekommen sind so durch diese krise
muss man sich schon mal fragen wozu
machen wir das alles eigentlich
überhaupt das heißt bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder csu chef
hat ja nach der letzten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gewarnt und
auch hinter den kulissen in diesen wir
schalten mit der kanzlerin gewann vor
einer pandemie der ungeimpften daran
glaubst du nicht
doch selbstverständlich aber das ist
doch eigentlich eine hervorragende
nachricht davor es war es eine pandemie
für alle und jetzt nur noch für die
ungeimpften und das sind gerade vor
allem jüngere menschen und es sind
menschen die sich selbstständig
freiwillig dagegen entschieden haben ich
bin doppelt geimpft aber ich will doch
diese menschen nicht versuchen vor sich
selbst zu schützen wenn diese menschen
zum teil aus der nachvollziehbaren
gründen sagen ich habe keine angst vor
corona ich bin zwischen 20 oder 30 oder
40 jahren als statistisch ist die gefahr
für mich fast nicht existent dann möchte
ich sagen dann lebt bitte so und ich
möchte diese menschen auch nicht
einschränken wir haben kein recht dazu
dennoch in die zahlen verliert ja gerade
wieder hoch und zwar alle zahlen also
nicht nur die instanz die liegt jetzt
bei über 60 in deutschland aber auch die
zahl der hospitalisierungen geht wieder
hoch also die zahl die man sich jetzt
auch nehmen will um die lage zu bewerten
ist das für dich ein grund um irgendwie
beunruhigt zu sein nein das ist es
derzeit nicht das interessante bei der
hospitalisierung rate ist ja es gibt
noch keinen grenzwert das erst mal
spricht darüber die hospitalisierung
rate ist jetzt die neue kennzahl aber
bei der inzidenz hatten wir diese klaren
zahlen die waren zwar frei erfunden man
hat sich an der willkürlich bestimmt 35
50 100 bei der hospitalisierung 's rate
ist das nicht so niemand weiß was für
uns sozusagen erlauben können und was
nicht und für die politiker wird es
schwierig damit zu argumentieren weil
präsidenten hatte man schön große zahlen
35 50 irgendwann 100 200 das klingt so
bedrohlich wir haben gerade eine
hospitalisierung rate von 1 comment was
corona patienten pro 100000 einwohner
ein 1,2 kommenden drei komma das wirkt
einfach nicht so dramatisch nicht so
besorgniserregend
[Musik]